There are a number of commercial
technologies for centralized HIE.
In addition, the federal government
sponsored the development of CONNECT,
an open-source solution for
centralized or
other models of health
information exchange.
CONNECT is a very robust, complex system
that uses web services to facilitate
connectivity with other systems.
Its architecture is modular with some
elements, as indicated by these colors,
being required, others being optional or
replaceable, and
still others being customizeable.
It's also a gateway to the proposed
National Health Information Exchange,
as shown here.
Why would some CONNECT modules
be replaceable or customizeable?